mein Name ist Dr Ulrich Koopmann ich bin
Staatssekretär im Ministerium für
Fasching forsching Fastnacht und
karnevalistik ja ich möchte heute hier
einmal einem Vorurteil entgegentreten
weil sie immer Horst mir von der CSU wir
sind so steif wir sind so staatstragen
wir sind so ja
konservativ und da möchte jetzt wirklich
sagen also nicht nur im Fasching oder
wir unser hoch geschätzter
Koalitionspartner sagen würde nicht nur
im vorhin
aber natürlich gerade da also da lassen
wir uns manchmal derartige krachen das
ist wirklich eine
also da sind wir manchmal fröhlich und
ausgelassen
das war hier Stichwort zeigen
so und schon streben wir auch dem
Höhepunkt entgegen also
jetzt nehmen wir irgendwo
die Stränge nehmen wir einfach einmal 8
Konfetti
und jetzt passt es auf Helau hi juhu
u hahaha
das war das und jetzt wird wieder
regiert ich sage immer Biers Bier und
schnapsi Schnaps und sieht dann bitte
die ganzen konkrete wieder in die
Staatskanzlei die braucht man nicht so
wieder gell und ihnen wünsche ich einen
schönen Fasching respektive vorschi
[Applaus]